riche en vitamine c b 5 potassium
phosphore les caramboles un joli fruit
et 3 les consommer jaune en jus très
frais pour le tonus et la vitalité
mais ce fouillis originaire d'asie n'est
pas du tout recommandé quand on souffre
d'insuffisance rénale
yolaine et mal ne frôle og 36 ans de
métier le répète très souvent carambole
et personnes dialysées ne font pas du
tout bon ménage
les insuffisants rénaux près dialyse
aussi hautement toxique du point de vue
neurologique et digestif et justement
c'est quelque chose qui est apparue en
fait nous sommes un petit peu surpris
nous néphrologue de voir une information
qui sort comme ça dans la presse mais en
fait effectivement nos patients sont
informés que la carambole toxiques le
fruit contient une neurotoxine qui n'est
pas filtrée par les reins le diabète est
en premier en cause d'insuffisance
rénale toute personne diabétique devrait
tout simplement éviter de consommer des
caramboles qui vaut mieux dire que cette
fric il faut pas consommer en quantité
en tout cas parce que si on a la moindre
attente parce qu'il y en a qui sont
diabétiques une atteinte rénale qu'ils
ignorent donc ces patients là sont
potentiellement peuvent avoir une
intoxication à la carambole on peut
rester dans l'ana consommation modérée
j'ai envie de dire parce que c'est
manifestement cette toxicité elle et
elle est réelle elle est démontrée et
donc on peut imaginer que des patients
qui ignorent qu'ils ont une atteinte
rénale peuvent être toxiques et de façon
grave parce que je répète que chez nos
patients
ce sont ces une consommation qui peut
être mortelle et en cas de nausées
vomissements il est toujours bon de
préciser à son médecin diabétique ou pas
c'est oui ou non on a consommé plusieurs
belgrade de carambole